What I want to talk about in this video
Is the concept of "modified"
So, let's look at some examples of averages
Which you have experienced most often in your daily life.
If you drive your car in the way
I looked at the speedometer
You'll see him driving quickly
35 mph, for example (35 mph)
Where the mph characters you see mean
35 miles
In the hour.
Well, what does that mean?
That means the number of miles you travel every hour
If you continue driving at this rate.
That is, it can be a measure of speed:
Indicates the distance you travel in the unit of time.
Mostly, when people talk about rates
That's what they're talking about
They talk about how much something happened
Per unit of time.
And not necessarily a distance per unit time.
It may be an average income per hour
For an employee doing something
The staff member may say that he is paid
He earns $ 10, so he gets $ 10
In fact, let me write the word dollars
Let unity become clearer
$ 10 per hour
$ 10 per
Again, this represents how much money
- And here we are not talking about the distance as before -
How much money does an employee earn per unit of time?
Although the rates are always seen
As the amount of time something happens for each unit of time
It can be miles per hour,
Or Amtara per second,
Or as in this case, it can be a staff wage.
It will be a dollar per hour,
However, the rates are not necessarily confined to these units.
In fact, you might say for example: "Well,
I love a certain kind of dessert,
But I am careful
Number of calories consumed "
Maybe you see somewhere
It has 200 calories
In each share
So this information tells us the number of calories
In each serving of dessert.
Such information usually tells us the amount of the quota.
The quota could be Cuba or 8 ounces or any other amount.
So I can say: "Well, look, if you take two portions,
Then I will consume 400 calories "
"In the same way, if I worked for two hours, I would get $ 20"
"Or if you move for two hours,
I will cut 70 miles "
If rates give you an idea
How fast something happened.
Or the amount of something happening
Each time something else happens.
Now, I can write averages
In a way that looks exactly like the proportion
There is a link between these two words (in English)
In view of their spelling
RAT, RAT
You see that their roots come from the same idea
In fact, this rate here, 35 mph
Perhaps he came from a question:
"If you cut 35 miles in one hour
What is the ratio? "
Rate
Mileage
To watches
Then she says "Well, I've cut 35"
"Mileage to hour ratio"
"Was 35 to 1"
Or maybe it was
70 to 2, or something like that
But in this case the ratio is reduced to
35 to 1
So, the ratio
You see it mostly written this way
Or maybe you see it this way, you see it this way ..
Sometimes you may also see it written this way
35 miles
On 1 hour
But in this way it is more like
The special case of the ratio which we call the "rate"
Because this amount is the same: 35
Instead of writing "miles per hour" complete
Mostly you'll see a shortcut
Mile / hour
All these ideas are interrelated
If you know the ratio between the number of calories and quotas
Then you will be able to write
You will be able to express it on average
vice versa.
Why do we care about rates?
Well, if we're talking about things like speed, for example
Without rates, then it will be difficult to determine how much
The speed of things happening.
In that case we would live in a world where we say:
"See, I'm faster than you" or
"It's faster than me"
But we are unable to identify
Their speed is exact.
While using averages, I can say: "Look, that person ran
100 yards in 10 seconds "
"Ran 10 meters per second"
We can determine exactly how quickly that thing happens
Or rate of occurrence.
In this example, instead of saying: "A cup of this
Will give you more energy,
Or maybe it increases your weight more
Of a cup of it "instead of these absolute comparisons
Here you can really quantify things
And when we study the rate
We will study the rate a lot in mathematics
Will be essential in algebra
When we look at the rate of change
Line For example, look at how fast it moves in the vertical direction
For its movement in the horizontal direction
We will call it "tilt"
You can even imagine the slope of a hill
But the speed of escalation for your movement forward
We will also look at the rates in detail
When we are in calculus
In fact, the origin of the science of differentiation
- which will be studied later in the secondary and first years at the university -
Is the measurement of intraday averages
That is, the speed of movement of something at the moment.
The rates are very pleasant too
Very very important
I can say that you are
If you care about life around you
Even if only for the next few hours
You'll see a lot more
Plenty of rates.